let's talk about relationships money how
that works in a relationship do you have
strong feelings or philosophies on how
money should work in the relationship
like is anybody in a relationship
currently
no does anybody have multiple
girlfriends that they want to admit to
on camera in front of people all right
that's me guys
um but all right let's start with
multiple girls i'm open about that
straight up yeah i tell every girl i
deal with i'm not going to monogamous
you that's stupid for me to do that you
tell them straight up i will not be
monogamous
i think it's absolutely stupid for a man
to be monogamous if you reach a certain
level
okay and when did this philosophy start
for you oh i grew up in a muslim
household right so you know it's kind of
already been something that i've seen
but um it's just it's just in i guess an
uncomfortable reality that here in the
west we don't want to accept is that men
and women are not the same so a man
having a lot of women is not the same as
a woman having a lot of men so once a
man and it's been that way since the
beginning of time you know kings sultans
rulers of you know countries or whatever
maybe powerful men have always had
hordes of women you know they might have
their main woman or two right that they
marry or have relationship or children
with but they'll have other women as
well so i think if a man works his ass
off to get to a certain point he should
be able to enjoy the fruits of his labor
and a part of that is the ability to
have sexual abundance
why do you think it's different from men
versus women we're biologically
different and that pretty much she means
just in that specific example
as far as like why can't women have
right like why is it okay for men to
have multiple women but it's not okay
for women to have multiple men oh no
women can absolutely do whatever they
want they can have multiple men too but
they're not necessarily set up for it
from a biological perspective and a
woman that has a lot of men is not the
same as a man that has a lot of women
because a man that has a lot of women
has to bring value to the world to some
degree versus a woman that has a lot of
sex with different men
loses her value
do you disagree with that how does how
does a man add value by having sex with
multiple women and how does a woman
devalue by having sex with multiple men
because men aren't measured on their
men are measured by the world what you
create you know your status your income
etc like men must go out into the world
and create and become a somebody and
then a byproduct of them becoming
somebody is women are attracted to him
there's a reason why you look at
musicians popular athletes etc they have
a bunch of women coming after them why
because they've accomplished something
in the real world and the byproduct is
the women so the women is not uh but for
women it doesn't necessarily operate
that way so a man having sex with a lot
of women you know he's doing something
right if you see a guy or an attractive
model but why for women does it not
operate that way because women aren't
the same we're just not the same
but you're saying like men are creators
like women are creators too we we we all
we're all creation right like we were
born in creation yeah so why are we not
creators
i'm talking about creating like going
out to the world and building and
becoming in the marketplace
you're talking to speak like completely
capitalistic not like contributing art
or culture or anything like that i mean
that could be a byproduct of it but the
man goes out into the world and creates
a last name that that woman fights to
try to get so here's what i want is the
reason why a woman takes a man's last
name and the man doesn't take hers okay
explain i would i would love to hear i
just explained it the man goes because
because of what he built so his legacy
yes he's going and building this name
and a woman wants to fight to get that
name from that man men lead women follow
but myron here's the question for you
bro yeah
you don't think it can be a a balance
like know your role no one somebody has
to lead and no one somebody has to
follow like both both men and women are
feminine and masculine energy like i
don't think a man always has to sit in
his masculine energy
men lead women follow well here let me
get to this point jenny hold on one
second then we'll get you're getting a
little
fired up i love it